it's been another long day for Matias so
go the 24 year old is finally on his way
back home he studies biology in Wagga
dugu and wants to be a food inspector
but for the past two years he's also
been pursuing another dream to become
burkina faso's first professional
cyclist and that means training hard
every day we include difficile it is
pretty tough you don't have time to do
things you enjoy like going out with
your friends with ewa Kleiza me in
cycling you have to make sure you eat
right and get enough rest dude ah yeah
so you have to go to bed early force him
out could you go up to saw goes family
helps him manage his stressful routine
today his sister-in-law is cooking his
dinner his family also supports him
financially this help is vital what is
he Danny my goal is to improve myself as
much as I can and to make a name for
myself people worked in one need that
way I can do something for people who
need help I want to serve as a role
model for young people in Africa Asia
and Africa salgo is an ambitious cyclist
his bike has to be in good shape and
everything checked before every race
and the amateur cyclist has been doing
well he's made it to Burkina Faso's
national team and he's already won a
cycling tour in Benin at this year's
Tour de foie so he's in the leading
group of the race it's a tough tour with
temperatures soaring past 40 degrees
Celsius the race is a triumph for the
young birkin Abby it's been his best
season yet what I wore today my goal was
to keep up with the other guys and do as
well as I could the people here were
really pleased that I came third game as
you see and I'm very proud of what I did
back at home salgo and his uncle are
already discussing the next steps in his
cycling career the bike Matthias is
using belongs to his club he now needs
money to buy one of his own what info
dl- sweetie I need financial support it
costs money to be a professional cyclist
these days you've got to master a lot of
skills to become a great writer and
Boise crees the to talk all afternoon
tomorrow saga will go back to university
but he's already imagining himself
cycling his first race through Europe